and she was using the money to gamble so
she owed her Mike ten twelve fifteen
thousand some like that so she said he
says look I'm gonna send you to Florida
to work for the dog track he didn't turn
her in because she's sleeping with him
doesn't want the wife to find out so he
sends her to Florida she meets me I'm
going on the run she wants in yeah
so you're an adulteress seething yeah
you know yeah so all attributes by the
way perfect beauty she comes so I say
okay you know you can come with me so
she comes with me we go straight to
Atlanta she rents a house we remove take
that I assume the guy who owns the
houses identity and I borrow like four
hundred thousand dollars and I pull the
money out we pull the money out and we
take off so now we got about four
hundred thousand branches that you
rented the house from yeah you rented a
house in Atlanta right in a neighborhood
in Atlanta right and then you how did
you give it four hundred thousand
dollars the for one hundred thousand
rented a house for like one ninety it
was valued about 190 so the value of
that house was 190 if it was okay right
so we're paying whatever is thirteen
fourteen hundred a month okay rent and
so what I did was I went downtown and I
he had a he had two loans on the house
from Bank of America and I created a
satisfaction of mortgage remember I told
you I dated a girl who worked for a
title company mm-hmm so I know how a
satisfaction what if tells that what a
satisfaction looks like right I create a
satisfaction of mortgage I then go back
down and I record it well what happens
is if you have a mortgage you have a for
instance your house right now
you've got up whatever two hundred three
hundred thousand dollar mortgage on the
house - let's say Bank of America okay
well when you pay that off how does
public records know what's paid off
right
Bank of America gets their three hundred
thousand well what they do is they then
create a satisfaction of mortgage they
then mail it in with seven dollars to
Hillsborough County right or what are we
in Pinellas or something else Pinellas
County public records and they say hey
the mortgage that was taken out to Danny
Jones on this day
for this amount of money satisfied its
here by Saturday with this loan number
or whatever number is hereby satisfied
they are who owned this house had no
clue that his mortgage was now satisfied
enough to of them so he has no clue and
all I did was make a fake ID I figured
out how to make like a fake ID so I
don't even have a real ID at this point
I just made a fake one I mean I did I
started going what happened was I
realized look making the fake ID is a
problem you gotta use the laminates you
have to get you have to overcome the the
issue of the of the hologram I mean you
have to rewrite it's a pain in the ass
yeah so it's much easier to just go into
the DMV and get you to issue us a
license in somebody's name to give them
to print it for you right so they
printed up so I just it's easier to just
deal someone's identity so then I very
quickly realized that but at this point
I needed his ID so I made I didn't have
his real middle name so I just made up
like it was like s well looks like the
middle name there's like Shawn so so I
end up making a name I don't have his
real date of birth keep in mind I just
need to go in and get a check yeah I
don't even have a social security number
I just needed then same name on the ID
because I'm borrowing from hard money
lenders so they charge like 14 percent
interest right right and so matter of
fact those guys a couple of them were on
American greed yeah there were 3 or 3/1
lent like 1/10 one let 150 another one
let 150 total came to like four hundred
thousand and how when you get the loans
from the hard money lenders how they
can't see that there's other hard money
lenders giving you who knows it's called
a shotgunning scam shot you mean and so
what happens is you do it so quickly you
apply with multiple lenders and you
close within a day or two of each other
okay and if you do that what happens is
the documents are prepared at the title
company you sign you get your check well
a couple of days later when they've got
all their paperwork done they mail it in
so these things get mailed into public
record saying this loan there's a new
mortgage on this property please record
it and here's the payment that may go
okay so public records puts it down and
they go okay here's the address here's
the folio number
yours okay okay boom record it two days
later another one shows up yeah Wow
they they go okay same thing there Oh
boom another mortgage no two hours later
boom Oh same one keep mine this woman
has she's doing this nothing that's all
she does all day recognize the number
then even if she did it's irrelevant
yeah you're allowed to have three or
four mortgages on the same property she
has no idea what it's valued at it's a
recording system not a verification
system they said they were court
documents that are mailed in that you
pay for and so they get it boom record
it record it record it so I got four
hundred thousand dollars I go open a
couple bank accounts mmm I deposit the
checks I remove the cash and that's a
funny story this is a funny story so I'd
go in I get a real driver's license
right in the name of a guy named Scott
cugno so I got a a Scott cogno driver's
license real license I have this real
soch
everything so one of the checks I had
issued to Scott cugno for 29 grand so I
go into SunTrust like walk into SunTrust
and I say hi Scott cugno I need to cash
this the guy goes twenty nine thousand
why don't you just deposit in your own
bank account mister cogno and I said
well because my bank account you know
I'm in Georgia it's in Florida I'm gonna
hold it for a few days and I need the
cash okay well okay well it's really odd
you know okay well here's my driver's
license here's my here's a credit card
driver's license here's my social
security card yeah I'm good you need a
thumbprint thumbprint
I'm already wanted yeah so you know he's
like okay we'll go ahead and have a seat
I have a seat my cell phone give my cell
phone is is your razor for my razor
razor motorola razr motorola razr is
there and becky's sitting in the car so
I wait the guy comes out and he says
okay this is like the president whatever
the manager of the bank he comes out he
goes okay um he said look why don't I
don't know [ __ ] what do you need the
cash for and I went I said we're I
cashed checks I said I'm a general
contractor I just did a job for somebody
they paid me with this money and
I have to I said I typically write
checks to the guys that work for me and
I cash the check so they don't have to
go to check cashing companies and he
goes okay that makes sense that makes
sense
you know something's wrong right yeah
right he just can't figure it out he
walks off but I'm not leaving yeah
something's wrong and you start asking
those questions you would leave most
people would leave but I know you can't
I'm thinking he can't he's not gonna
figure this out yeah so the phone rings
boom boom phone rings I pick it up it's
Becky
she goes hey she said what are you doing
what's taking so long I went calm down
the guys he's a jerk you know he's been
a jerk about it didn't want even the
money well then leave I go no no I can't
leave I said he's he's he's checking on
stuff but she goes well I go look look
calm down as she's all nervous yeah if
the cops show up
you see too if you see two cruisers pull
in call me yeah I'll run out the back
you meet me at the at the 7-eleven down
the street right so she's like okay okay
hang up the phone few minutes later he
comes out he asked some other question
what about this what about that what I'm
like where'd you get the check I said I
I got the check from the homeowner and
he goes okay and I said wait I don't
understand what's taking so long I said
it's a cashier's check written from your
bank yeah
the money is good yeah like no the money
is there it's just we have to there's
certain protocol we have to go through I
said okay okay so he leaves phone rings
again
what are you let's take a saw I don't
know guys a dick I don't know what to
say he's taking forever he's he's
checking like checking on what I don't
know comes out again and I said hey what
is taking so long and he goes well we're
trying to eat turns out that the name of
the guy is Michael Shanahan that the guy
that owns the house and I went okey
Brian I'm Michael shining right you're
Michael Conahan so I went okay and he
says and we're just trying to get a hold
of mr. Shanahan he's the guy who did the
work for us is right here we're just
trying to verify the check with him
they're now trying to get in contact
with Michael Shanahan Wow
who I've pretended to be using this zone
right and I'm one and I've already
signed that for the check I borrowed
400,000 so I'm like jesus H Christ
so the phone rings again it's Becky boom
hey what's
she owes what is taking so long I said
he's trying to verify the check with
Michael Shannon and she it was complete
silence and she's like I can't get out
of the bank I'm walking out with the
money if the cops show up call me and I
hang up the phone so I'm sitting there
the phone rings again I look at the
phone I don't recognize the number it's
a bank I pick up the phone I go hello
they go hi Michael Shannon this is
Jennifer from SunTrust Bank and I'm like
you she's right behind a glass cubicle
you're looking right at her actually
talking yes and she goes hi we have we
have a Scott cugno here at the bank he's
trying to cash a check then apparently
you had issued off of a refinance that
you made and I oh yes we just need you
to verify the amount and that it's mr.
yeah I believe it's Scott code no I'm
pretty sure it was for 29,000 even
mm-hmm and she's like that's right and I
appreciate it and thank you very much
real quick I said how did you get my
number this is number's unlisted she
goes oh we called the title company and
they gave us the phone number had she
called information she'd have gotten the
rip Michaels the real guy but she called
the title company because they did have
it that's where they banked right so she
called them they gave her the number
they call I said okay she's I hope it's
not a problem not a problem no big deal
thank you very much boom hanging at the
phone sorry
Wow so yeah so the guy walks out five
minutes later counts out 29,000 dollars
and stares at me and he gives me the
twenty nine thousand and I remember I'm
I'm cautious but I'm also feeling real
cocky oh yeah so I stand up and he goes
mister mister cogno he said I'd like to
uh I'd like to let you know I feel very
apprehensive about this transaction I go
really what is it exactly I'm not
stuffing money in my yeah what is it
exactly and he goes he said I can't put
my finger on it
I go I'm sure it'll come to you and I
walk off I get in the car tell Becky
what happened I'm like I believe [ __ ]
drive off I mean
like oh my god oh my god wouldn't never
I never even tried to cash a check for
that large ever ever since then it was
always under 29 it was always under
10,000 Wow mmm hi there's over that they
give you they investigated more well
yeah I mean I don't know what that keep
mine I had been doing like nine thousand
seven thousand eight no problem no
problem and then I one time I finally
went you this is taking forever
what do I care they can throw out a CCR
I don't care call the IRS I'll be gone
before they show up
so I didn't care um you know which was a
mistake because had he made just the
wrong copies just luck oh yeah let me
call you when you're in the bank that's
crazy
so that's the same we got all the money
we take off I we left with the four or
four hundred thousand change what did we
do oh yeah no it was more than that left
the house in Atlanta
yeah because where did you go after that
well you know what's funny is I I
totally neglected to mention the other
like we borrowed my weed also gone into
Tallahassee and done the same thing in
Tallahassee oh really that was
uneventful regular it's it's pretty bad
when you getting about them the the
hundred thousand you stole here are the
two hundred thousand here and you're
like now what happens I feel bad about
that don't judge me he's got this look
like this
the actual Michael Shannon on the house
ah very upset Michael so is he out of
all that like his house has now paid off
well yeah they don't look but that's not
really it's not really paid off what
happens what happens is he can claim
against the the title insurance okay you
know and that's one of the things that I
you know it's like I'd very easily
justified in my mind I'm just borrowing
money from the bank and I never really
thought I was screwing over those people
that owned the house because of
insurance because they have I go is got
title insurance right and for example
the guys in the in the show mayor
greed they talk about how one of the
guys got paid back from the title
insurance and the other guy says he
didn't get paid back now it's my
understanding that that although all of
them had gotten paid back but in the
show he says he didn't get paid back so
he may not have been paid back I'm not
sure how that's possible I mean the the
title policies been produced that way
well I think it may be they just fought
it but I mean look you've got a title
policy that that that ensures you
against fraud one of the one of them is
or cloud it's got a clouded title
whatever the case may be it was very
clear that it covered fraud he should
have been paid back now whether he was
or not I don't know he says he wasn't I
he's not listed as far as I can tell on
the people that I have to pay back I
believe that the title agency that he
got the loan from probably paid them
back but somebody owns that agency and I
probably owe them the money you know
it's like look somebody somewhere got
[ __ ] over right so I take the money we
take the money we go to Charlotte North
Carolina how much money do you have at
that time like five six hundred cash
right in cash in a little duffel bag
then it's not done you know you ever see
those guys it's like it's like half a
million dollars it's and they're your
money because that's not songs about
fifties you know it's not that much
money
[Laughter]